THE FBI PROBE INTO BRETT
KAVANAUGH COULD BE FINISHED IN A
MATTER OF HOURS.
THE BUREAU EXPECTED TO WRAP
THINGS UP AS EARLY AS TODAY.
SOURCES TELLING FOX NEWS A
SINGLE COPY OF THE REPORT WILL
BE SENT TO CAPITOL HILL AND THE
WHITE HOUSE TO READ AND THEN
IT'S GOING TO BE KEPT IN A SAFE.
THIS ALL COMES AS SENATOR CHUCK
GRASSLEY IS DEMANDING ANSWERS TO
STARTING NEW ALLEGATIONS THAT
CONTRADICT CHRISTINE BLASEY
FORD'S TESTIMONY.
AN EX-BOYFRIEND CLAIMS FORD
HELPED A FRIEND PREP FOR A
POLYGRAPH TEST.
CONTRADICTING HER SENATE
TESTIMONY.
>> HAVE EVER HAD DISCUSSIONS
WITH ANYONE, BESIDES YOUR
ATTORNEY, ON HOW TO TAKE A
POLYGRAPH?
>> NEVER.
>> I DON'T JUST MEAN
COUNTERMEASURES, BUT I MEAN JUST
ANY SORT OF TIPS OR ANYTHING
LIKE THAT.
>> NO.
>> HAVE YOU EVER GIVEN TIPS OR
ADVICE TO SOMEBODY WHO WAS
LOOKING TO TAKE A POLYGRAPH
TEST?
>> NEVER PRAYED >> Jesse:
FORD'S FRIEND IS DENYING BEING
HELD FOR A LIE DETECTOR TEST.
PRESIDENT TRUMP ISN'T BACKING
DOWN FROM DEFENDING KAVANAUGH
FROM DEMOCRATIC ATTACKS.
>> THEY HAVE BEEN TRYING TO
DESTROY JUDGE KAVANAUGH SINCE
THE VERY FIRST SECOND HE WAS
ANNOUNCED.
SO MANY DIFFERENT CHARGES.
GUILTY UNTIL PROVEN INNOCENT,
THAT'S VERY DANGEROUS FOR OUR
COUNTRY.
A MAN'S LIFE IS IN TATTERS.
A MAN'S LIFE IS SHATTERED.
THEY DESTROY PEOPLE THEY WANT TO
DESTROY PEOPLE.
THESE ARE REALLY EVIL PEOPLE.
>> Jesse: AFTER THE BOMBSHELL
STORY ABOUT KAVANAUGH THROWING
ICE CUBES AT A BAR,
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" OUT WITH
ANOTHER DECADES-OLD REPORT ABOUT
THE SUPREME COURT NOMINEE.
THE TIMES PRINTING WHAT APPEARS
TO BE A SARCASTIC LETTER FROM
KAVANAUGH PREPARING FOR BEACH
WEEK IN THE SUMMER OF 1983 WHERE
HE WARNS ABOUT HIM AND HIS
FRIENDS BEING LOUD AND GETTING
DRUNK.
ALL RIGHT, GREG.
I GUESS THIS IS A SWORN
STATEMENT BY THE EX-BOYFRIEND OF
FORD AND ITS RIDDLED WITH
BOMBSHELLS.
NEVER BROUGHT UP ANYTHING ABOUT
KAVANAUGH, NEVER HIS NAME, NEVER
BROUGHT UP ABOUT BEING ABUSED.
HE WITNESSED HER PREPPING A
FRIEND OF HERS, MONICA.
FLEW ALL THE TIME.
NOT AFRAID OF SMALL SPACES.
WHEN HE CAUGHT HER CHEATING, SHE
ENDED UP KEEPING HIS CREDIT CARD
AND THEN SPENDING LAVISHLY ON
IT, THEN LIED ABOUT IT
AFTERWARDS.
ONCE IT WAS SAID THAT HE WAS
GOING TO PRESS CHARGES, THEN SHE
OWNED UP TO IT.
>> Greg: THE KEY THING TO TAKE
FROM THIS IS THE TWO CAN PLAY
THIS GAME IN THE COURT OF PUBLIC
OPINION.
WE HAVE SAT HERE AND WATCHED
UNCORROBORATED ACCUSATIONS SO
NOW THE PENDULUM IS SWINGING
BACK AND THAT HAPPENS TO BE
INFORMATION OUT THERE.
THE MEDIA IS SAYING THAT TRUMPS
COMMENTS ABOUT FORD WERE A
MOCKERY OR AN ATTACK, THEY ARE
THE SAME MEDIA WHO THOUGHT MATT
DAMON'S RIDICULE OF KAVANAUGH
WAS SPARKLING AND BRILLIANT AND
DARING.
THEY FIND TRUMP SAID SOMETHING
YESTERDAY AND HE -- THEY CALLED
IT MOCKERY OR AN ATTACK WHEN ALL
HE DID WAS POINT OUT A
DISCREPANCY.
WHAT TRUMP DID, IF THAT WAS AN
ATTACK, THEN YOU REALLY DO LIVE
IN A BUBBLE.
IF YOU GO HOME OR GO TO A BAR OR
TALK TO SOMEBODY AT THE GYM,
WHAT TRUMP SAID IS EXACTLY THE
OPINIONS OF EVERYBODY AT HOME
GOING "SOME OF HER STUFF HAS
HOLES IN IT BUT STUFF ABOUT
HAVING ONE DRINK BUT NOT
REMEMBERING EVERYTHING ELSE."
THE COMMON SENSE, WHAT WOULD YOU
CALL, THE RALLY TRUMP, IT
REFLECTS MOST OF AMERICA AND HE
IS REVEALING THE CONTRAST OF THE
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE EXPRESSION
ABOUT THIS CASE, THAT SO MANY
PEOPLE PUBLICLY WILL SAY SHE IS
CREDIBLE AND COMPELLING.
BUT THEN THEY GO HOME AND GO
DUDE.
SHE IS NOT MAKING SENSE.
REMEMBER, HE SAID AT THE
BEGINNING, COMPELLING.
BUT THEN WHEN HE GETS TO RALLY
TRUMP, HE BECOMES LIKE EVERYONE
ELSE AND SAYS THERE'S SOME
INCREDIBLE THINGS.
>> Juan: RALLY TRUMP, HE FEEDS
RED MEAT TO THE RED BASE.
AND YOU'RE GOING TO GO AFTER THE
PRESS.
THE MEDIA IS DOING THIS.
LET ME TELL YOU.
PICK UP THE PAPER.
YOU WILL SEE PEOPLE LIKE SUSAN
COLLINS ARE SAYING THIS IS PLAIN
WRONG.
>> Greg: BECAUSE THEY ARE
SCARED OF THE MEDIA.
>> Juan: LET ME FINISH.
>> Greg: YOU INTERRUPTED ME.
>> Juan: I DID NOT.
YOU HEAR LINDSEY GRAHAM SAYING
THERE MAY BE HOLES BUT
MR. PRESIDENT, KNOCK IT OFF.
>> Greg: THEY ARE WRONG.
>> Juan: THIS KIND OF GOING
AFTER SOMEONE WHEN THEY GIVE YOU
A -- BURYING THEIR SOUL ABOUT
SOMETHING THAT IS TRAUMATIZING.
WOMEN GET A MESSAGE THAT THEY
ARE BEING TOLD SHUT UP.
>> Greg: WOMEN AGREED WITH
DROP BY THAT RALLY.
THEY APPLAUDED.
>> Juan: HOW ABOUT WHEN THE
CLASSIC TRICKLE CATHOLIC CHURCH
ABUSES SOMEONE.
>> Greg: WHAT ABOUT THE
CATHOLIC CHURCH?
[ALL SPEAKING]
>> Judge Jeanine: WOMEN IN THE
ELEVATOR, THEY GO TO THE OLD
WATER.
IF YOU SUPPORT --
IF YOU WERE MOLESTED AS, IF YOU
WERE MOLESTED, GO AFTER THE GUY
WHO MOLESTED YOU.
DON'T ASSUME BRETT KAVANAUGH
SHOULD CARRY THE BURDEN FOR
EVERYONE WHO HAS SUFFERED, EVERY
WOMAN, FROM SEXUAL ABUSE.
>> Juan: EVEN JEFF FLAKE SAID
WHAT TRUMP DID LAST NIGHT, NO
TIME, NO PLACE FOR SOMETHING
LIKE THAT BECAUSE IT'S
INSULTING.
THE LAWYER FOR FORD SAID THIS IS
WHY WOMEN DON'T COME FORWARD.
YOU DON'T TELL YOUR DAD.
YOU DON'T TELL YOUR MOM.
>> Greg: SIMPLE DISCREPANCY.
>> Jesse: SARAH SANDERS WAS
ASKED ABOUT THIS TODAY.
LET'S HEAR WHAT SHE HAD TO SAY.
>> IT WASN'T ANYTHING OTHER THAN
THE PRESIDENT STATING FACTS,
FACTS WERE LAID OUT IN THE
PROSECUTOR'S MEMO THAT SHE PUT
FORWARD TO THE SENATE.
IT'S DISGRACEFUL WHAT THEY HAVE
DONE AND EXPLOITED THIS PROCESS.
THEY EXPLOITED DR. FORD.
THEY ARE EXPLOITING ALL THE
WOMEN WHO HAVE COME OUT TO MAKE
ANY TYPE OF ACCUSATION.
THIS ISN'T THE PROCESS THAT
SHOULD'VE BEEN DONE AND
CERTAINLY EVERYBODY DESERVES TO
BE HEARD THAT INCLUDES JUDGE
KAVANAUGH.
>> Jesse: I JUST GOT A FRESH
TEXT FROM MOM.
I'M GOING TO HAVE TO GO TO YOU.
"I SINCERELY HOPE DANA
ESTABLISHES THE TONE TONIGHT
REGARDING ATTACKING THE VICTIM."
HERE YOU GO, DANA.
>> Dana: I WAS -- FERRIS
SANDERS REPRESENTS HER BOSS WELL
SANDERS REPRESENTS HER BOSS WEL.
NOBODY TALKS LIKE TRUMP.
NO ONE CAN OUT TRUMP TRUMP.
YOU ARE THE PRESS SECRETARY.
SHE DID HER BEST THERE.
WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS SAYING
WAS BASICALLY READING FROM THE
TRANSCRIPT OF THE HEARING.
IT'S THE TONE.
LIKE YOUR MOM SAID.
FOR ME TO SET THE TONE FOR THE
PRESIDENT HAS A TONE THAT DOES
SOUND LIKE HE'S GOING AFTER YOU.
LIKE FOR ME, YOU KNOW I HATE
NICKNAMES.
I GET IT THAT THEY WORKED IN
THAT THEY ARE VERY EFFECTIVE.
I DO WONDER ABOUT THE STRATEGY
LATER ON BECAUSE FLAKE,
MURKOWSKI, COLLINS, THEY WOULD
NEVER SAY THIS KIND OF THING.
THEY ARE ALREADY UNDER A TON OF
PRESSURE.
THEY ARE WAITING FOR THIS FBI
REPORTS.
THE PRESIDENT NEEDS THEIR VOTE.
I THINK, FROM A STRATEGY
STANDPOINT, DO YOU GET THE
COUNTRY WITH YOU AND LOSE THOSE
THREE VOTES AND THEN END UP
WINNING IN 2020 BECAUSE PEOPLE
ARE SO MAD?
OR DO THOSE PEOPLE, THOUGH
SENATORS COME AWAY FOR THE FBI
REPORT.
IF IT'S CLEAN, THEY HAVE NO
REASON NOT TO VOTE FOR HIM.
IF THE FBI REPORT COMES BACK AND
IS FINE.
>> Judge Jeanine: I REALLY
BELIEVE DONALD TRUMP ALWAYS HAS
BOTH SITUATIONS COVERED.
HE HAS THE PUBLIC SITUATION
COVERED AND THE POLITICAL.
THAT'S WHY HE PLAYS TO HIS BASE
AND HE ALSO IS TRYING TO
LEVERAGE HOWEVER WAY HE CAN GET
THESE SENATORS.
>> Dana: I THINK HE WILL END
UP WITH -- EVEN IF HE LOSES
FLAKE, DIZZY PICKUP
MANSION -- DOES HE PICKUP
MANCHIN?
>> Jesse: WE HAVE ALL SEEN
TRUMP MOCK.
I DON'T THINK THAT WAS HIM
MOCKING.
>> Greg: PEOPLE PUTTING THEIR
SPOTLIGHT ON AVENATTI AND
LETTING IT RIDE IN THEN YOU HAVE
TRUMP BRING UP A SIMPLE
DISCREPANCY.
YOU CALL THAT ATTACKING?
GIVE ME A BREAK.
>> Juan: I WILL GIVE YOU A
BREAK.
THAT WAS AN ATTACK.
IN OTHER WORDS, EVERY WOMAN IN
AMERICA --
>> Greg: IT'S NOT EVERY WOMAN.
>> Juan: OH, THEY ARE ALL
SNOWFLAKES.
WANT YOU JUST SHUT UP AND MOVE
ON.
NOTHING TO SEE HERE.
>> Greg: THAT'S NOT WHAT IT
IS.
>> Juan: PART OF THE ISSUE
WITH THE FBI, THE FBI -- THE
PRESIDENT SAID HE FOUND FORD
CREDIBLE.
NOW HE CHANGES HIS TUNE BECAUSE
HE WANTS TO PLAY TO YOU, GREG.
>> Jesse: JUAN, JUAN.
>> Judge Jeanine: EVERY WOMAN
IN AMERICA WHO HAS BEEN A VICTIM
OF SEXUAL ASSAULT REMEMBERS MORE
THAN CHRISTINE BLASEY FORD.
I KNOW.
I DID THIS FOR 30 YEARS.
>> Juan: I AM SAYING YOU THINK
YOU ARE SPEAKING TO EVERY WOMAN.
>> Judge Jeanine: KNOW, WHAT
I'M TELLING YOU IS FOR YOU TO
SAY BECAUSE DONALD TRUMP IS
POINTING OUT INCONSISTENCIES IN
HER OWN TESTIMONY THAT HE IS
SUGGESTING TO OTHER WOMEN WHO
HAVE BEEN VICTIMIZED THAT HEY,
LOOK, WE'RE NOT GOING TO BELIEVE
YOU, IT'S NOT THE CASE.
WOMEN WHO HAVE BEEN VICTIMIZED
ARE ASKING THE SAME QUESTION.
WHY DO I REMEMBER?
WHY DO I --
>> Juan: MOST WOMEN WHO WERE
VICTIMIZED DON'T REPORT IT
BECAUSE --
>> Judge Jeanine: NO KIDDING.
WHAT THEY FEAR IS NOT THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES